انتهاك خصوصيه الاطفال والاحتفاظ
ببياناتهم دون العوده لاهاليهم وموافقتهم
هي اتهامات تواجهها شركه تكنولوجيا
العملاقه
لجنه التجاره الاتحاديه الامريكيه اعلنت
بان مايكروسوفت ستدفع 20 مليون دولار
لتسويه هذه الاتهامات والتي وجهتها لها
اللجنه بخصوص الاحتفاظ ببيانات الاطفال
بطريقه غير قانونيه واضافت اللجنه هنا في
بيان بان الشركه جمعت معلومات شخصيه من
الاطفال المشتركين بنظام اكس بوكس للالعاب
الفيديو طبعا دون اخطار الوالدين او حتى
الحصول على موافقتهم كما يلزم الامر
الصادر او يلزم هذا الامر الصادر عن
اللجنه مايكروسوفت باتخاذ خطوات لتحسين
اجراءات الحمايه وتحديدا حمايه الخصوصيه
لمستخدمي نظام اكس بوكس وبرامج الفيديو من
الاطفال تحديدا وهنا قالت اللجنه بانها
ستوسع نطاق قانون حمايه الخصوصيه وخصوصا
خصوصيه الاطفال على الانترنت ليشمل طبعا
جميع الشركات الناشره لالعاب والعاب
الفيديو التي تشارك مايكروسوفت بيانات
الاطفال معها مايكروسوفت بدورها هنا
اعترفت بالفعل لكنها بررته بانه خطا فني
من النظام يحتفظ بالبيانات تلقائيا مؤكده
بانها ستحل هذه المشكله قريبا لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات